[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suis pas c'est vrai un seul défaut
cette man
moi tu vas
une vie de galères et 1
mais quand je sors et qu'ils le gardent
c'est toujours encore un gain
c'est sympa
tout m'est avis le sont
on est star est plus grand
the beast en janvier
sur des épées
avec l'italie
et puis chants pour kléber plus un rugby
audois
debiais par celui-là des angles tournoi
est très jolie petite balade vélo cinéma
bref il se doit
pour voir les whisky à gogo c'est pas
mal au froid casse un peu tout ça
je
c'est ressayres - baladez vous taire je
suis cette date
l'appel basbug
diop
je fais du chemin
tous les matins
car j'adore la de l'odeur du gratin je
ne fréquente que des larmes
prenons comme nous
je déments
abo
et quand je parle
ouais
on se réunit
les années
tous les erp ed
pour faire d'esprit ya les coquins en
des deux seins et du caire envers mange
à la petite cuillère
pardon
jean je vous dis à moi
on peut y arriver le plus bas j'avais la
télé et soit m'ennuyais
je
retournez l'autre côté ce n'est plus par
g
or
[Musique]
6dans en live
je passe le moins d'eau opéra
c'est vrai
si les aigles selon m
rassure
encore plus rêve de tout à l'heure
et quand je sors
je souhaite
j'ai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]